[Música]
hola les damos la bienvenida a enlace
centroamérica desde san salvador- en el
programa de hoy haremos un recuento del
tercer año de gobierno del presidente
buque le hablaremos de sus más recientes
medidas entre ellas haber solicitado un
estado de excepción con el fin de
combatir a las pandillas el cual fue
aprobado por el congreso y está vigente
desde el 27 de marzo también revisaremos
cómo ha escalado la atención entre el
ejecutivo y la prensa luego de conocerse
el espionaje con pegasus el software con
el que fueron espiadas unas 40 personas
en su mayoría periodistas de igual
manera abordaremos uno de los
principales desafíos de lo que resta de
la gestión gubernamental de bukele
mejorar la situación económica de la
población de más bajos ingresos debido
al aumento del costo de la canasta
básica es precisamente el manejo de la
economía del país el talón de aquiles
que pueda afectar su mandato en el
futuro cercano ya que tendrá que lidiar
con un alto endeudamiento público y la
introducción del bitcoin como moneda de
curso legal medida sobre la cual muchos
salvadoreños dicen no percibir algún
beneficio
según recientes sondeos de opinión buque
le llega a su tercer año de gestión
manteniendo aún una alta aprobación
entre la población este respaldo le
permitió declarar una guerra abierta a
las pandillas a través de la
instauración de un régimen de excepción
que ya lleva 90 días algo inédito en el
país no obstante diversos organismos han
recibido cientos de denuncias de
atropellos a los derechos humanos
principalmente por detenciones
arbitrarias cabe decir que esta medida
suspende cuatro garantías
constitucionales el derecho a la
libertad de reunión y asociación el
derecho de defensa la inviolabilidad de
la correspondencia y comunicaciones y se
extendió el plazo de la detención
administrativa de 72 horas a 15 días
estos dos meses de vigencia de las
autoridades han detenido a más de 35.000
personas duplicando el hacinamiento
carcelario
se han vulnerado en este régimen de
excepción este diferentes diferentes
principios
el estado no ha demostrado qué
digamos capaz de por los medios
ordinarios controlar la situación de
inseguridad pública que se vivía en ese
momento según una investigación del
medio digital el faro la ola de
homicidios que dejó 87 víctimas y
propició la declaración de régimen de
extracción se dio tras la supuesta
ruptura de un pacto entre el gobierno y
la pandilla mara salvatrucha el gobierno
no ha respondido oficialmente a esta
acusación y ha comenzado el descrédito y
acoso a medios de comunicación y
periodistas la asociación de periodistas
de el salvador ha señalado que nueve
periodistas salieron preventivamente del
país para esta organización el ambiente
para ejercer un periodismo independiente
o no afín al oficialismo es más hostil
que nunca las transgresiones varían
desde la negación de información hasta
ataques en redes sociales a esto hay que
agregar los saqueos y el espionaje
digital tal como le ocurrió a más de una
treintena de periodistas mediante el
software pegasus a inicios de año
el estado salvadoreño se desligó de las
acusaciones de espionaje y en su momento
afirmó que bajo ningún concepto ejerce
persecución contra personas o entidades
críticas al gobierno junto a esto se ha
reformado la ley para establecer penas
de hasta 15 años de prisión a
periodistas que publican mensajes
producidos por pandillas que puedan
generar sus obras este año el salvador
cayó 30 posiciones en la clasificación
de libertad de prensa uno de los
retrocesos más dramáticos del continente
latinoamericano informó reporteros sin
fronteras
si yo tengo que ver hacia atrás este año
ha sido particularmente peor que los dos
años primeros porque este año sentaron
las bases justamente para
esa criminalización del ejercicio
periodístico
bukele se apalanca en la popularidad
para impulsar medidas polémicas lo he
hecho en materia de seguridad y también
en materia económica fue el caso del
bitcoin que tras casi un año de adoptado
como moneda de curso legal sigue siendo
muy poco usado entre los salvadoreños y
ha afectado negativamente el nivel de
riesgo del país
una encuesta de la universidad
centroamericana arrojó que la situación
económica es el principal problema tanto
del país como de las familias estudios
revelan que el 45 por ciento de la
población afirma que los alimentos son
el rubro que más ha tenido incremento de
acuerdo a datos oficiales la inflación
en el último año superó el 6% un alza
del costo de la vida que no se veía en
el salvador desde el 2011 los más
afectados son los trabajadores
independientes quienes tienen empleo
formal se beneficiaron con un aumento
del 20% al monto del salario mínimo pero
de acuerdo a un estudio del centro para
la defensa del consumidor sólo alcanza
para un poco más de la mitad de lo que
una familia necesita para cubrir sus
necesidades básicas
casi no se hayan trabajos
la canasta básica está bastante elevada
no apuesta para la unión uno gana otro
gran reto inmediato que tiene buque es
el de las finanzas públicas por ahora
arrastra el endeudamiento más alto en la
historia del país también tiene en sus
manos la reforma fiscal y el sistema de
pensiones las decisiones que tome sobre
estos temas podrían afectar la intención
de reelección que aunque actualmente no
está permitida en la carta magna una
resolución de la sala de lo
constitucional ya abrió esa posibilidad
hasta aquí con este enlace a
centroamérica desde el salvador gracias
por habernos acompañado y para ver
nuestros programas síguenos en france 24
y france24 puntocom